I'm here today to tell you a
couple stories about optimizing
things for Android Wear.
And, well first off,
little bit about myself.
I'm an engineer on the
Android Wear Frameworks Team.
I spend a lot of my time doing
battery life optimization
among some other things.
And I've been
developing for Android
since the dark days of
Cupcake many, many moons ago.
And, yeah, I guess
the only other thing
to mention-- I'm Canadian so
if you see any funky spelling
and so on and so forth
that's because-- that's
how you spell English, and
that's real Queen's English.
And, yeah, so first off
the most important part
about optimizing Android
Wear is, well, battery life.
Pretty self explanatory.
The worst thing you could
possibly have on a watch
these days is one that
has a blank screen.
We all kind of
like-- and our users
all like having a
screen that's always on.
Its always got information,
and you can always glance at it
and see what's up.
So there's a couple
challenges when it comes
to optimizing for battery life.
And, well, the screen
being on all the time
is actually a
pretty big problem.
To actually have
the screen on, we
have to make a lot
of compromises.
And there is actually-- the
watches are pretty good.
They've gotten enough
performance to run Android.
It's got enough performance
to run full videos
and that tends to be a problem.
Because if you run full
videos on your watch
they don't tend
to last very long.
So, yeah, there's quite a few
things we have to deal with.
If you want a very, very,
powerful device that
can last a long time, you could
strap your phone to your wrist.
But that's also not very pretty.
So, yeah, we have now three
tales of battery life.
These are sort of
cautionary tales,
sort of campfire ghost
stories of things that have,
well, let's not say happened.
But lessons that we've learned.
So first I want to start
off with the watchface.
So this watchface wants to be
really, really, really pretty.
And how you make a
really pretty watchface,
well we start with, like,
gorgeous animations.
And I'm talking,
like, animations
that have a slowly moving second
hand that sweeps gracefully
across the screen.
It's got cogs basically
taking away the background--
just gorgeous watches.
Well there's a big
problem with that.
Animations are very powerful.
They're great.
They're gorgeous, but
they're really power hungry.
If you have an animation
that runs every time
your watchface shows up
from its ambient mode.
So every time you look at it
it does a little animation.
Yeah that's perfectly fine.
Half a second
animation, what not.
But if you have to keep an
animation going all the time,
well, the application
processor is
going to have to calculate all
those-- all the pixels moving.
Everything on your watch
is running at full speed.
Your watch is going
to heat up and it
drains a lot of battery life.
So probably want to
avoid having animations
that run all the time.
So you want to pick the
best spots for animation.
Well the other problem with
animations, and Android Wear
actually, on phones
you don't really
get screens that change in
the refresh rate very much.
They're almost all
universally 60 Hertz.
So we target 60 frames per
second then [INAUDIBLE].
On watches because we are
using really small screens,
very power efficient
screens, they're
only guaranteed to be
operating at 30 Hertz.
And this is sort of even
more compounded by the fact
that some screens
work slightly faster,
some screens may even go
all the way up to 60 Hertz.
But you're only guaranteed
to work at 30 Hertz,
so your animations
actually have to look good
at 30 frames per second.
Which isn't a big
deal, but if you're not
aware of it you will suddenly
pull out your watch and go,
this animation
doesn't look good.
No matter what I do, no
matter how fast I render it,
no matter all the
little hacks I do,
it still looks like it's
running on 30 frames per second.
That's not, like,
something broken.
That's actually how fast
the hardware can possibly
render because the screen
is very energy efficient.
That said, you still want to hit
60 millisecond frame rendering
target that you need for
60 frames per second.
Because other watches
will have better screens.
So your watch may not be great,
but-- have the greatest screen
refresh rate, but your
other users may do.
And finally, somebody
will always ask you,
you know what, these
watchface, the animations,
they're great and all.
But we can save
more battery life
if we turn on hardware
acceleration, right?
And we get asked this
basically once a month.
Somebody will
think-- will ask hey,
can we turn on
hardware acceleration?
We're trying to
save battery life.
So in this watchface
in particular,
we actually sat down
and we measured current.
When you turn on hardware
acceleration and you
have a 50% increase
in battery drain which
actually kind of makes sense.
When you turn
hardware acceleration,
you're actually using more
silicon on the actual device.
Normally things that
wouldn't be running
would now be running
in-- because they're
accelerating the graphics.
So, yeah, you don't-- if you
need hardware acceleration you
should totally use it to
get better frame rates.
But if you don't need
it, turning it on
won't help your battery
life whatsoever.
So something to keep in
mind that it's not magic
that you sprinkle
on top of whatever
animation you're doing.
It actually has
cost involved in it.
So this gorgeous
animating watchface
had this other thing
they wanted to do.
And they wanted to have
photos, and specifically they
wanted to pull up photos
from the actual phone
that this watch was paired with.
And you have giant
bitmaps that they
wanted to render in a screen.
So they had really,
really big bitmaps
that sucked up a
lot of memory which
became a bit of a problem.
Because these devices don't
have a lot of memory on it.
They have about half a gigabyte
of memory and that's it.
Now that's more than
enough because the screen
with the biggest resolution
is currently the Huawei watch,
which is 400 by 400 pixels.
Not a lot of pixels to push.
You don't need gigantic 15
mega-- megapixel photos,
but they sent it over
on the Bluetooth radio.
A radio that needs to slowly
send every byte on both your--
from your phone to your watch.
So now you're draining
battery from your phone.
You're draining batteries
from your watch,
and that didn't
work out very well.
And we'll just say that once
we actually got the phone
to actually shrink the images
beforehand, and send it
over that way, battery
life became a lot better.
Things sent a lot faster
for some odd reason.
Apparently if you send less data
over, it sends a lot faster.
Watchfaces are always loaded
on your watch in the sense
that every time your watch
goes back to the watch mode,
you see a watchface.
Seems obvious,
but that does mean
that anything that is
running on your watchface
is loaded in memory.
Which means that if it
takes up a lot of memory
the application you
just used is now
garbage collected and stopped.
So it means that you want to
be a good citizen of Android,
and actually not use too much
memory if you don't have to.
So that other applications won't
randomly shut down every time
you-- and take longer
to boot up every time.
So taking all these
things into account,
we end up with a
watchface that actually
is fairly power efficient
on many, many devices.
But we pulled it up
on certain devices,
and suddenly the
battery life jumped up.
Sorry, the battery
life jumped down,
the battery
consumption jumped up,
and it was really strange
because it was only
a certain class of devices.
And those are specifically
devices with OLED screens.
OLED screens are not
like LCD screens.
We have watches
that implement both.
Just so we have watches
that have OLED screens
and you have watches
that have LCD screens.
And OLED screens
have to emit light.
They emit light from
the individual pixels,
which is fairly obvious.
But that means that if you
go with darker palette,
it needs to emit less
light, and therefore it
takes less battery life.
On a LCD screen
it doesn't matter,
so if your watchface
is completely bright,
it's got lots of
colors in it, it's
going to cost the same
amount of battery life
as if it's completely dark.
Well, similar amounts.
On OLED screens,
a dark background
saves you a lot of power
in comparison to say,
a completely white background.
So something to keep in mind.
But if you take
that into account,
then you will have
similar performance
across both watches that have
LCD screens and OLED screens.
So with that, this is
basically the rough ways
to actually make a
watchface not suck up
say, four extra hours of
battery life of your watch.
We don't always have
to use a watchface.
It's a full Android system.
We have apps.
We have apps that we can run.
So a classic app that we
run is The Fitness App.
So this is The Fitness App,
in which first time I got it,
you pull it up.
I click on the icon
and I wait, and I wait,
and I wait, and I wait.
Wait for a long, long
while for it to load.
By a long while I actually mean
like about a second and a half
or so.
Look whenever I'm
using a watch, you
use it for about five seconds.
You pull it up, you tap tap,
look at some information,
it's done.
If your app takes a really
long time to start up,
it's not ideal.
You're going to suck up a
lot of the users' time just
waiting for things to boot up.
So because you want
to use the launch as
little as possible
rather for users
to use the watch as
little as possible.
You want your watch
to go back to sleep.
That saves power, so you
wanted things to load quickly.
So the best way of making
things load quickly is
don't load things
that you don't need.
So, yes.
Don't do things you don't need
to do, like all Android apps.
But I mean even things
like loading classes
can take a while.
Loading big images
Loading data from the SD card
that you could defer later on
could take a while.
So one of the things
that's important of a watch
is more so than phones,
because phones, you
get a splash screen.
I've already pulled my
phone up, I've unlocked it.
Taking an extra
second, not a big deal.
Taking an extra second for
a watch to load up actually
pretty big deal.
Especially if I'm only using
it for a couple seconds
to look up some information.
So-- and of course, as I
mentioned before for watchface
is, if you use a lot of memory
you'll kill other applications.
And if you exit your app, and
if you use a lot of memory,
the system will also
remove your app for memory.
Which means the next
time you open it is also
going to take longer.
So you want to actually
keep your memory usage
low even for an application.
So for a fitness app, if
you do any work at all,
it has to use sensors.
If you don't use
sensors, fitness app
doesn't really do anything.
It just sits in your
watch and probably
tell you some information.
So-- and the nice things
about Android Wear
watches is that they have
full suite of sensors,
just like most Android phones.
And picking the right sensors is
also actually really important.
Accelerometers are great.
I love them.
They use very little power.
And for almost all our watches,
our accelerometers actually
have some built in
memory inside them
that allow them to
actually operate
without the application
processor in your watch
from doing anything.
Which means that it actually
takes a lot less power
to gather data.
So you don't have to be running
an application completely
while collecting
minutes of data.
And that's really important
because that actually
will reduce the overall power
use if you use accelerometer.
Gyroscope, on the other hand,
doesn't have that neat feature.
It doesn't batch
any of the data.
And more importantly,
accelerometers
use about a tenth of the
power as a gyroscope.
So if you're doing your
own motion algorithm,
if you're doing
your own gestures,
and playing around with that.
Couldn't say they're just
trying to get everything
to work with the accelerometer.
Like Android, you
want to use sensors
as little as possible, by
which I mean you don't want
to use it if you don't have to.
So you can do things like
[? lure a ?] sample rate.
If you [? lured ?]
a sample rate,
you can actually match
up more samples of data
before it actually
runs out of the memory
and sends it all to your
application to work with.
And of course, you want to
turn off the actual sensor
if you're not going to use it.
There may, or may
not, have been issues
where an application
would turn on a sensor
and then just keep the
sensor on indefinitely.
Bit of a problem when
you're trying to save power,
especially if you're
trying to sample data
at this highest
possible rate possible.
So you want to be
very, very careful
in dotting your I's, crossing
your T's, shutting down
things when you don't want to.
So once you've
gathered the data,
one of the things that
all fitness app like to do
is they like to synchronize
with some server somewhere.
So they use a network
to send some data.
So the important thing
about sending data,
again, use as little data as you
can possibly can get away with.
So one thing not to do is to
send all your logging data
about how to send
network information,
as a part of network
information to send back,
that tends to not
work very well.
Especially if you end up in a
situation where, say, you send
100 kilobytes of
data, and that gets
followed by 200 kilobytes
of logging data.
Something to avoid perhaps.
But the timing of
sending network data
is actually pretty
important, too.
So say I'm accessing information
from a phone frequently,
and I have to do it quite a bit.
And every time I do it,
I do it every-- I only
collect like two, three bytes.
Not a lot of information
to send, right?
I'm following-- sending
as little as I can.
But every time I
ask for information,
it's-- I have to ask
every 10 seconds.
Every 10 seconds I've got
to send a couple bytes.
Well, the Bluetooth radio has
to turn on-- well, is always on.
Which is great.
Bluetooth radio on your
watch is almost always
on unless airplane
mode is turned on.
But just because it's
turned on doesn't
mean it's operating
at the same power.
If it's idle, it doesn't
use much power at all.
If it's not idle, it actually
has to spend time to ramp up.
Has to connect to your phone.
It's connected to
your phone, but it
has to actually tell your phone,
hey I'm about to start talking.
That takes power.
And then has to send
the information, which
takes more power.
And then actually
shuts back down which
actually takes even more power.
And all those things takes
a couple-- a half second
to start up.
A half second to shut
down, and if I'm only
sending two bytes of
data, that's, well,
maybe about 10 milliseconds.
But your 10 milliseconds
of data being sent actually
cost a whole second of the
Bluetooth radio turning
on and off.
And if I do that
every 10 seconds,
that soon becomes
a huge problem.
So what you want to do is you
want to batch all those data.
So usually, you don't
really need immediately
to the second data
from the launch--
from the phone to the watch.
So you want to batch
it so that you may
want to send it once a minute.
And why I mention
once a minute is,
well, your watch actually has
to do something every minute.
Especially when your
watchface is on.
That's the update,
well, your watchface.
Every minute when your time
ticks, your watchface updates.
And if you're going to
have to do some network
synchronization, you want to
do it when it actually ticks
and during that time.
You want to do all that
work at the same time.
You want to dog pile
together, and then stop.
So if you developed
a watchface that
needs data to be
synchronized every minute,
maybe you want to synchronize
five seconds beforehand.
Instead of, say, trying
to keep the entire watch
on by synchronizing at
random frequent intervals.
So sending a lot
of little things
can be really bad, so you
want to batch it together.
But you still want to send
as little as possible.
So the other thing
that is really bad
is listening to intents that
are frequently dispatched.
By which I mean we
may have encountered
a situation where a certain
fitness app was keeping--
was sending data every time
you turn the screen on.
By which I mean every time
you look at your watch
it would send data to
the phone, and then
request it on the phone.
And then every time
the screen turns off
it would do the exact same.
And if you wear an
Android Wear watch,
you'll note that you
actually look at it
every now and then a lot.
Every time you look at
it, it would suck up
a tiny bit of memory.
Sorry, a tiny bit of
energy and do it again,
and again, and again.
So it's not the greatest
thing in the world to do that.
It may or may not have dropped
battery life a couple hours.
All these little things
add up over time,
especially if you operate every
time any minor thing changes.
So please don't do that.
Please avoid intents that
are dispatched a lot.
And if you absolutely have
to, please stop using them
if you don't need them anymore.
One of the things a
lot of people forget
is that you can actually disable
listeners, especially-- even
broadcast receivers that you
registered and you manifest.
You can disable them in code
when you don't need them,
so something to keep in mind.
You don't always have
to run when you're
listening for certain intents.
Even if it's set up
in your manifest.
So that's basically it
for our fitness app.
We have an app that efficiently
gathers your fitness data.
We have an app that actually
sends data in a very power
efficient way.
So I'm walking down the street.
Done my run, want to go home.
One of the things that
is really nice for me
is that getting
transit information.
So I want to talk about
the transit app that I got.
Popped up my watch and I said
hey, great, got a new transit
app.
I tap, it opens up, tells me
the time the next bus is coming.
All right, OK.
I got to run to
the bus stop now.
And I start running, and
take a quick look at my watch
again after a minute or two.
The app is gone.
So me being a guy that
likes [? my ?] [? launch ?],
I said hey, you know
what would be great?
If you could just keep
telling me that information.
I'm looking at the
transit information.
Odds are I'm
occasionally running
to the bus stop in a hurry
because I woke up late.
So the person said oh sure,
we can keep the screen on.
By which he meant he kept
the full wake lock on.
Which meant the screen
was permanently on,
full brightness,
the entire time.
It's not-- please don't do that.
It means the
[INAUDIBLE] processor
is running really, really fast.
It drains a lot of
energy when it does that.
The screen is on.
It also doesn't
work really great
when your screen is
on at full blast.
Wayne earlier talked
about a couple modes
that you could use.
So interactive
mode, when we call
something interactive
mode, that's when, like,
you can touch the screen.
It's got the test sensors.
You can buttons, and
so on and so forth.
That's what happens when
you keep full wake lock.
But in Android Wear,
we introduce something,
we call it Ambiactive mode.
What that means is that
your app is running,
but the screen has turned off.
By off I mean in the sense
that the screen isn't active.
This touch screen is off.
You can't touch buttons.
You can touch the touch screen
and it will switch it back
into interactive mode.
That's actually pretty
great because what
that does is that
you can actually--
your app can actually give
the system a particular image
to display on the screen.
So you can be like, you
can turn all your texts
to a certain color, say white.
Turn your background to black.
And the screen-- the watch
will just keep that image on.
It's great for stopwatches,
it's great for transit apps,
it's great for keeping power.
Because your screen
no longer has
to be running at full blast.
The system doesn't have to
be operating at full blast.
The system actually
turns off a lot
of the silicon involved
with displaying.
Because it doesn't have
to actually receive
any new information now.
All it has to do is just display
that one image that you've
pushed through the screen.
So that's great.
You can turn on the
Ambiactive mode.
I can now use the actual
app and see my transit time.
You can update the image every
minute, or half a minute,
or whatnot.
And it's useful.
And it's actually
one of things that's
most useful about this device.
You can actually
create applications
that can take over
the entire screen,
and be used the entire
time, without creating
your own watchface.
Because I may like my transit
app, but on a day to day basis,
I don't need it to
be my main watchface.
I don't want to keep
switching my watchface.
I like my watchface,
it's pretty.
It has nice colors in it.
The other thing
about Ambiactive mode
is that the 5% screen
use is still important.
You-- OLED screens have a
very bad tendency to burn in.
By which I mean, back in the
olden days, we had CRT screens.
We had plasma screens.
And if you, like, kept them at
the same image on the screen,
or like kept the Weather
Channel on, or MTV on.
It would burn in
a-- you would have
a burn in ghost of an image.
OLED screens actually
have the same problem.
It's not a big deal on
phones because, chances are,
your phone aren't going to
be stuck at the same image
and turned on all the time.
But the problem with watches
is that you got your watchface
to do that.
You have the same time
ticks and stuff all over it.
So you only want to use a very,
very small bit of the screen.
And we do our own magic to
shift the actual image around
in order to combat burn it.
So screensavers
are kind of back.
So yeah, that's something
to keep in mind whenever
you're doing Ambiactive.
You don't-- while the system
can definitely hold the screen
that's completely bright on,
it's not great for OLED screens
because it wears them out.
So the transit app, we
ended up getting rid
of the Ambiactive problem.
The active-- it doesn't
hold a wake lock anymore
that keeps it on at full
screen all the time.
So we were looking at
other ways to improve it,
and one of the problems
that we were having was
that we found out
that it was getting--
it was hitting network a lot.
By which I mean every
time you would move, like,
a couple hundred meters, it
would refresh all the traffic
data-- all the transit data.
Because, well, we had another--
we got to another bus stop
and it's got new
data to update here.
So this is great for
certain applications.
But for applications where
your data changes a lot,
it's not so great.
I don't-- I love my transit, but
I don't actually need to know
when the next bus
stop is all the time.
I kind of just want to know
when I'm trying to commute home
or something.
So your users may not
always want to use your app.
You surprisingly may not always
be the most important thing
on the launch.
I mean, I know it's surprising
that whatever application
that we are developing isn't
the greatest thing in the world.
But data that gets stale,
and you have to load again,
and again, and again.
Not so great.
You may want to actually
start loading the data
whenever the user opens
up the application.
Now that does mean
that it is not
as responsive as we possibly
want the actual application
to be.
But that is something
that a design decision.
We have to, sort
of, work with that
and decide to take-- what not--
taking up more of the user's
battery life overall is good,
or where not being slightly less
responsive is good.
So we err towards the side of
an on demand synchronization
model.
At-- so when the user wants
to actually get the data
and provide it.
The other thing to,
sort of, going back
to the fitness model.
You want to synchronize,
maybe, once an hour or so.
Not every time the user
takes a couple steps.
Seems obvious in retrospect,
but you can usually
get away with it when you have a
giant battery strapped to, say,
a phone-sized body.
The luxury of doing
synchronization
like that is not so
much when it comes
to having a small battery
on a wrist mounted device.
So with the transit
application, the other thing
that's real important
is, of course,
for it to get location data.
Without location
data it can't really
tell me where my bus stop is.
So the problem with asking
what location it is,
is that it's kind of crafted
for both the phone and watch.
So you could grab location
data from the GPS.
We have one device right now
that's the Sony SmartWatch 3,
and it has built -in GPS.
And it's pretty much
just as bad as when
your phone uses the GPS.
It takes up a lot of power.
It's actually kind
of a bit worse
because the battery
inside a SmartWatch
is smaller than a phone.
Surprise, surprise.
So GPS is even
more expensive when
it comes to how
much battery life it
drains from your device.
But even grabbing from the
network is also expensive.
Your phone actually
talks to your watch,
and tells it what the
actual location is.
Because, of course, your
phone has a bit more
buffer when it comes to
grabbing your location.
Your phone also
has a cell radio,
and we can do fancy stuff with
that to grab your location.
But when you use your Bluetooth
radio to send information
it drains battery
life from the phone.
It drains battery
life from your watch.
And if you say grab the location
information every five seconds,
assuming that it'd be just
like grabbing it from a phone.
It may drop your battery
life by two or three hours.
I mean, not saying
it's a terrible idea,
but maybe you should
avoid grabbing location
data every five seconds.
One minute's great,
maybe five minutes.
Maybe only grab it when you
absolutely, positively have to.
But just certain things
to keep in mind whenever
you're grabbing location.
It's not exactly free,
and on a watch more
so it can drop your battery
life by a very, very substantial
degree.
So know it a bit early, but this
is basically it for my tales.
I kind of have a
couple themes that I
think are-- I've sort of
harped on quite a bit.
You don't want to
do much, or rather
you want to do
everything you can
to make a good user experience.
But you want to use everything
as little as you possibly can.
Use less sensors.
Don't grab as much
location data.
Use the screen as
little as possible.
Be conservative in
your animations.
When you work more
with Android Wear,
you can find its kind
like an Android phone.
Like everything
impacts an Android
phone in terms of battery life.
Also impacts an Android Wear.
I mean, pretty much,
it's the same device.
But because of the smaller
battery, because we want small,
nicely sized wrist watches,
as opposed to giant cuffs
on our wrists.
The-- any little
drain is amplified
in the overall battery
life of the device.
So you'll want to be really,
really careful whenever
you make decisions on whether
or not an extra feature is
going to be a very bad impact
on your users' overall battery
life.
And if you have to
do certain things,
like sending network
information, getting sensors.
Sort of batching everything
together is great.
You want to dog pile to get all
your work together, and then
allow your device
to go back to sleep.
So sort of the
overall features, you
want your device to sleep
as much as possible.
Because then it could
last as long as it can.
So that's basically
it for my talk.
I have my Twitter
handle up there.
You feel free to message me.
I can talk on, and on,
and on, and on about all
the different little things
when we talk about battery life.
But that's basically the things
I want to, sort of, talk about.
And my colleague, Wayne,
is doing a code lab
on Android Wear
development, if you
want to get your
hands dirty on that.
And he's just in code
lab room over there.
And, yeah, I'll be
here to take questions.